to england where prime minister boris
johnson has announced a new set of
covert restrictions starting tomorrow at
the same time he's facing a scandal that
could undermine his authority overall
we've got raymie andosencio for us
outside 10 downing street that's the
prime minister's home in london where he
had a party last christmas face some
criticism for that raymie good morning
good morning tony and the mood here is
one of resignation that this is a
setback in terms of the freedoms and the
mobilities that britons have been able
to enjoy for much of the past year but
prime minister boris johnson is now
saying that these covert restrictions
are for the protection of the people
this plan b and it is not a prelude to
another lockdown
but from monday you should work from
home if you can
go to work if you must but work from
home if you can alright i know this will
be hard
for uh for many people
uk prime minister boris johnson
announcing the strictest covet
prevention measures since this summer
after a dire forecast of an exponential
rise from about 500 known omicron cases
now to more than one million by new
year's in just three weeks starting
friday face masks will be legally
required in most public indoor venues
and starting next week double
vaccinations or a negative test will be
required at large events
but johnson said people should not
cancel their christmas parties just as
he's suffering a crisis in confidence
after leaked video from a rehearsal
press conference inside ten downing
showing his staff strongly implied they
flouted coveted restrictions with a
christmas party there in 2020
[Laughter]
this fictional party was a business
meeting
and it was not socially distanced
allegra stratton johnson's press
secretary at the time tearfully
resigning late wednesday i regret those
remarks for the rest of my days and now
for my profound apologies to all of you
at home
and forcing an apology from the prime
minister i'm sickened
[Applause]
but sorry may not be enough for those
who did follow the rules but lost loved
ones during the pandemic
and all of the uk's new code
restrictions will be coming into force
by next week but the question is whether
the people will actually follow it
especially after prime minister boris
johnson's government advisers this time
last year apparently flattered those
rules then nate
raymien ocencio in london thank you